and finally new rules someone has to
tell me Johnny oh that we sure jump that
someone has to tell me why Americans
won't take anything seriously unless
it's delivered with a British accent why
in movies even ones where the actors are
Americans playing people who are not
British they still put on a British
accent here's Brad Pitt as Achilles
muhammadans my brother's of the sword
he's from the Midwest and we know the
ancient Greeks were not but neither were
they from Notting Hill so why does he
have to say for why is sword more
serious than sword
here's Marlon Brando as Superman's dad
old and I have old and I've been
everything I feel Brendo the greatest
actor ever you mean even he can't talk
America did biblical people have British
accents like Jennifer Connelly here in
Noah I can't bear to think of her 600
year old husband is putting three
million animals on a houseboat but she's
using a British accent because she
doesn't want to sound silly
in World War two movies even the Nazis
have British accent Game of Thrones
takes place in a world completely
made-up by a dude from Bayonne New
Jersey and they all have British accents
last season ended with the King dying on
the toilet done with an English accent
classy when Elvis did it just gross
obi-wan Kenobi lived in another
millennium in a galaxy far far away
so naturally he had a British accent as
did the bad guy in the movie and even
the [ __ ] robot
and I bet if you cracked open the other
robot that only made beeping noises
there'd be a guy in there with a British
accent alright I'll stop but before I do
did you know that among the many items
that are sold as part of the
merchandising for Fifty Shades of Grey
there is a butt plug advertised online
the Fifty Shades of Grey something
forbidden silicon butt plug using
something forbidden is deliciously to be
that's right if you have an English
accent you can literally tell us to
stick it up all right yes that's for
real or that our dick doesn't work
you've seen the viagra ads you know what
plenty of guys happy face you're not
just getting an erection but keeping it
just like a sexy Mary Poppins just a
spoonful of sugar makes the ding-a-ling
pop up
oh you were a flaccid loser now you're
the dick of Windsor ha ha so what is
going on here oh I think we know what's
going on Americans we talk a big game
about were the greatest country in the
world an American exceptionalism in the
indispensable nation yeah yeah you know
whenever I hear someone bragging on
themselves like that
I always think they're covering up a
massive insecurity and our reliance on
the British accent to convey gravitas
it's kind of our way of admitting that
we know we're not really a serious
people I mean come on we drink wine out
of a box we invented Mormonism our
best-selling author is Bill O'Reilly
most Americans don't know that the Big
Bang Theory is also a theory
I mean look look at all the childish
stuff that defines America superhero
movies climate change denial Palin's
Pharrell's hat pajama jeans for people
who want to wear pants but don't want to
feel overdressed at Walmart come on
we know us we know we're the folks who
gave the world Kim Kardashian's giant
ass
and when I say Kim Kardashian's giant
ass of course I mean Kanye with
and therein lies our special
relationship with England they have the
gravitas we have the swag it's how we
act it's what we do it's who we are
we have the aircraft carriers but they
have the guy who knows a sentence needs
a subject at an object oh yeah that more
sounded a whole lot better coming out of
Tony Blair's now which is why the
British accent is dangerous and it
should always come with a warning that
this movie isn't really that profound
this reality show judge isn't really
that smart this war isn't really that
good an idea and this product still goes
in your butt